ask the audience if they had any
nicknames and we did get a few in
uh harry harry olefson harry
harry yeah that's me
you you you you and now your nickname
was
first off the name ari it's icelandic so
i'm familiar with
skater i like it
yeah i do we all like it
i
[Music]
your nickname your nickname was yeah i
uh i feel quite ridiculous saying this
now that i've actually seen the man
but a few years back some people in
iceland actually started calling me
ashton because they thought i looked
like him
it's spitting image bud to be fair
graham he has
makeup on
i would like you to know and i will let
the world know you can come inspect if
you would like
i refuse to wear makeup on talk shows
i never do never not once
have i ever and you can come look if you
want good sir
that's all i need baby
i blame the long dark winter night sid
i've got four pounds of makeup on
what was it what was your full name uh
first off i actually quite like wearing
makeup
you're the most weirdly aggressive
icelandic
[Applause]
the youngest man alive move the pole
but can you still bust a move now
[Applause]
[Music]
oh here we go
[Applause]
oh
wow
[Applause]
oh
the ultimate the ultimate move he did
was called the windmill
with the nutcracker wow
you can't do that at 17 years old he
just popped the windmill and came out of
that with the nutcracker and
i'm impressed on this show
when you walk without spoken about other
television chefs
do you consider yourself a tv chef i
don't really know no no i'm a proper
chef
he doesn't you very you don't sit there
much demonstrating recipes no
no it's not you know it's you know i
cook live every day so
sometimes we see these tv chefs and they
sort of turn around and look here's one
i made earlier or you know welcome to
ready steady [__]
um it's it it's really
want no no but i i'm aware
it's real because we cook every day and
you know i enjoy life i like that
jeopardy i don't want to see things done
by home economists well listen we're
always on the lookout for uh the next tv
cookery star so what we're going to do
now
we're going to see i'm liking this game
and what we do is we're we're going to
find you a new commie chef
right so we have some candidates lined
up in the kitchen white
and we're going to interview them right
now the only
rule is they mustn't use the f word by
which i mean they mustn't use
any word beginning with f
okay that sounds easier than it is
okay so uh let's uh let's go
so forget this is my buzzeroffie thing
so let's meet our first coffee chef
hello i'm here hi what's your name what
brock brock yeah
okay yeah uh describe some of the things
hanging on the shelves behind you
uh trout very good bird-like things
crusty sticks um a cooling device
what's what's that thing over there big
metal thing with
a refrigerator
[Applause]
okay what's 5-1
i'm [__]
hello hello
hello hello hi how you doing what's your
name
uh jonathan jonathan all right uh
what sort of fries are in the oven
uh they're actually called chips
actually [__]
they're chips and fish that's what
that's what they're called
[Applause]
well i wasn't even listening
hello hello hi what's your name zack
what is it zach zack yes spell it
what spell it gordon wants you to spell
your name zid ak
said ak poison f no i wondered why you
wanted to spell zack
are you going to keep in touch are you
going to write to it
and what are your favorite foods zack
well i'd have to say ice cream is one of
my favorite foods i like
i like good
hello hey hi what's your name dan
what daniel daniel okay uh and uh what
do you like to cook daniel
stuff
what white flower what what's what's the
white substance uh
on the counter behind you powdery [__]
what's on the counter in front of the
fig pie
some more of that powdery [__]
all right
[Applause]
i said can i say it yeah i said i called
they asked me what i thought of russell
crowe and i thought for a second said
a [__] [__] and so they said
nothing and then two men got a hold of
me and just checked me off of me
and i'm old and i kept thinking
osteoporosis we're going to hear crack
crackers
why would they call themselves loose
women and then not let you swear
why would they call those loose women
and talk about not having sex and then i
come on and say
[__] and they talk about not having
don't ask don't stop don't go
so people are always saying you know
what haven't you done your career
well another milestone i was thrown off
for saying [__]
okay i'm so excited
so is this this a steinway what's
happening it's gorgeous
um
[Music]
what do tigers dream of when they take a
little tiger snooze
do they dream of mowing zebras or halle
berry in her catwoman suits
don't you worry a pretty striped head
we're gonna
get you back to tyson and your cozy
tiger bed
we're gonna find our best friend and
then we're gonna give him my best friend
[Applause]
but if he's been murdered by crystal
meth tweakers
well then we're [__] out of luck
[Applause]
together because something like you know
say the time
open brackets dirty bit those brackets
were you watching dirty dancing and kind
of went
oh yeah i like this song i might do
something with that we're in ibiza
and um we're getting ready for a dj gig
and uh i'm like what i gotta drop
something for tonight
and so me and my my homeboys ammo and
apple
homeboys meaning people that are close
to me
that where i feel like chums chums like
a charm
it's me a few of my chums were chumming
it up
[Applause]
i asked him what are we going to play
tonight
unexpected and he said
we should mix something from yesterday
old school from old school
right yeah elementary old school meaning
you know back in the day back in the day
yeah yeah let's pick something from back
in the day
and you know flip it up
intertwine it with
today's stuff i mean use it
so i say
why don't we use dirty dancing and then
he replies
[Applause]
that's crazy we can't use dirty dancing
i was like but that's the whole point
you don't say i about i was like that's
the whole point but i might
say that you said that's an old boy you
don't need
like right by the way everybody
please stop using the word like
[Applause]
it's quicker it's like it's not life
it is yo what are we gonna do today i
don't know what we're gonna do
so he was like and i was like and so
then we put it on the table and it was
like bam
i've got a feeling
[Applause]
is the cleverest and funniest man of the
20th century and i just
he's kind of my hero and he wrote a song
called the elements because he was a
scientist and it's basically it's the
name of every element
in the periodic table um and that's
that's my party please it's quite long
so do stop me if you just get bored
okay but i will this kept me up last
night i was so nervous about doing this
um or do i feel bad now
okay so there's antimony arsenic
aluminum selenium hydrogen and oxygen
nitrogen and uranium and nickel
neodymium neptunium germanium and
americium ruthenium uranium europium
zirconium reticulum vanadium anthem and
aspirin acetyne and radium and golden
prototypium and the neem and gallium and
iodine and thorium enthusiam did a
little a little
there's a tremendous rubidium and born
galileo
sunderland silicon silver and bismuth
let's start next first
there's hormone and healing the nephew
and erbium phosphorus and francine and
fluorine and terbium and manganese and
mercury lived in magnesium dysprosium
and scandium and cerium and cesium
there's lead procedinium platinum
plutonium
potassium polonium and tantalum
technician titanium delirium and cadmium
the calcium
there's sulphur californium and fermi
and bacillium and also
[Applause]
[Music]
tungsten and sodium
she's actually put up with me for seven
years now
seven years seven years and over the
last few months
she's been dropping lots of hints um
about me asking her something and i
thought
i would ask her
[Applause]
no
oh
don't rush
this is a bit of a walk to the gallows
wasn't it
[Applause]
seven years i was sort of winding it up
okay here we go oh oh oh what's happened
what's happened
has anything happened since no have you
had a row you made up
okay okay so now i've brought you this
hamster
here we go this is i think this is me
okay off you go
faye i love you you marry me
[Applause]
[Music]
you